they look for that thing that that did
lose you at that point I thought this is
what I do with my life and nothing
matter being famous
being rich nothing only doing this
desire can sometimes trump talent he's
an American actor filmmaker and
screenwriter he's had an acting career
spanning 50 years and along that way has
received numerous awards and accolades
his performance as Michael Corleone in
The Godfather is widely regarded as one
of the greatest screen performances in
film history he's Al Pacino and here's
my take on his top ten rules for success
rule number two is my personal favorite
and make sure to stick around all the
way to the end for some special bonus
clips also as Alice talking if he says
something really meaningful to you
please leave it in the comments below
and put quotes around it so others can
be inspired as well you look for that
thing that that moves you I don't know
what it is I like repetition I there's a
saying goes rep repetition repetition
keeps me green yeah I love that same
repetition keeps me green keeps me green
become fresh because the idea that we do
performance is over and over again you
would say well doesn't that get boring
or stale but no it's in the repetition
that the creation comes that the
expression comes because I'll give you
an example I was doing Richard once not
particularly well and this show is going
on and we couldn't get this um court
scene with a lot of people in it I
didn't understand what I was doing in
the scene
so we would call rehearsals I would
rehearse it and stuff
and we would talk about it think about
it you know like all
this kind of work where people together
are trying to figure out something in
the 85th performance of Richard I had
done my 85th entrance
I knew the court scene I understood it I
I was there I could play but not in 84
not maybe four I was I might have been
getting closer didn't realize it yeah I
gave up the ghost I guess I just gave it
up and said I'll screw it it's not gonna
happen and I'll just keep going on and I
found it all train compartments smell
vaguely if it gets so you don't mind it
that's the worst thing that I can
confess you know how long it took me to
get there a long time when you die
you're gonna regret the things you don't
do you think you're queer I'm gonna tell
you something we're all queer you think
you're a thief so what you get befuddled
by a middle class morality get shut of
it shut it out I cheat on your wife you
did it live with it little girls so be
it there's an absolute morality huh
maybe and then what if you think there
is go ahead be that thing bad people go
to hell I don't think so you think that
at that way
Alex is on earth yes I won't live in it
I would like to be someone who takes
chances I think part of the adventure of
it is to is to go into something and and
and not be afraid to screw up because
then you're reaching for something
drei why are you doing this Roy no I
mean it say it say Roy Cohn you are
homosexual and I will proceed
systematically to destroy your
reputation and your practice and your
careers I think what happens is you
learn to forgive yourself because it's
you see in the scheme of things how it
is and you say well gee you know I tried
it the worst thing as they say is not to
go for it
but if you go for it and it goes you
know it's out of your hands and it's
like that was saying what any what
anyone ever says about me is really none
of my business so you know you sort of
you go and then you hope for the best
and then you see that a lot of times you
know things happen and you have no
control
[Music]
why that's got a it's getting messaging
Johnson I respect what he's done
new overthrow CEO it's natural
how could you do business with it's
getting
I'm a businessman first foremost I want
the further comfort with him you telling
for me then he can live where he can
dine Vincent will you stop
[Music]
Joey Zasa get me doing this not just
what I thought I was out they pull me
back in if you're gonna make a movie
right now the whole idea is that you you
make a movie about something and to be
able to make a movie about something you
know something that's sort of in your
wheelhouse so to speak it's something
that you relate to it's important
because making a movie is so hard it's
very difficult to to put get a movie
together and oh man you know you've
heard it many times but to have
something you feel you understand that's
why I had a lot of fun doing a movie I
made called looking for Richard yes it
was sort of about actors trying to
figure out how to do Shakespeare than
people and everything else and so it had
a very visceral connection to it well a
movie a book about an actor going
downhill and losing it and getting older
and falling apart seemed very
appropriate for me you know and I
thought this is uh this is going to work
one thing that bothered the one thing
that stayed in my mind and I couldn't
get rid of it that haunt it was why why
would she lie what was the motive for
lying if my client is innocent she's
lying
why
was a black male was it jealousy no
yesterday I found out why she doesn't
have a motive you know why because she's
not lying and ladies and gentlemen of
the jury the prosecution is not going to
get that man today no because I'm going
to get up
I want him dead book I want this no fair
step and I want Tracy dead
what's the matter your bums forgot how
to kill people doesn't your work mean
anything to you anymore have you no
sense of pride in what you do no sense
of duty no sense of destiny
I'm looking for general why do I got
foot soldiers
I want Treasury that I often say to
people who talk to me about Shakespeare
who never are not actors or directors
I've ever played it or done it the actor
learns Shakespeare in another way
because he learns it having to do it
having to spend months with it so he
approaches it in that way and
understands it in that way and the
familiarity with the words and the
phrases and what the content is what
it's saying becomes a part of you and
the revelations keep coming long after
you closed in in a play you know you you
learn things and you hear things in a
way that you could never if you saw the
play or if you read the play no that's
why act isn't a way of lucky that they
get an opportunity to that's why some of
the great ones that had the repertoire
of placing it so wanted to do it because
it had so much in it it's almost I can
come close to say say you were a cello
you played the cello or something and
you were playing Bach on the cello I
mean wow
imagine that you know so so that that
that manifestation of spirit which comes
out of it changes you it lifts your life
that does it gives you some
and once that a that appealed to me when
I was very young I was a very young guy
when I started to do Strindberg and and
things like that was very affected by
that because I thought here it is with
this material it's like playing the
cello because I can kind of just express
things in myself and it made me sort of
universally it gave me a more universal
sense of things and myself because I was
doing things that happen abused years
ago I was out of the South Bronx I was
out of the life I come from into another
world it was giving me all this stuff it
was a gift and I knew from that point on
age 21 I knew at that point I'd been
acting since I was this big
but at that point I thought this is what
I do with my life and nothing mattered
being famous being rich nothing only
doing this now at 21 that's easy to say
you know it's just you and pizza but it
is true that did happen
how many Ferraris you sold this month oh
it's not relevant to this discussion
Freddie the 80s are over are you trying
to tell me these things are just walking
out of the store this is a Ferrari sure
this is the finest piece of machinery
made in the automobile industry well if
you like it that much wanted to sleep
with it why are you selling it listen
I'd love to accommodate you but if this
car performs the way I expect it to you
will get a certified check of one
hundred and one thousand and change when
you come in here tomorrow morning so
hundred nine thousand plus nine hundred
and fifty dollars plus tax Freddie for
you
107 all in plus a case of champagne go
with your leftover turkey what do you
say don't worry about the boy he drives
so smooth you can boil an egg on the
engine when we bring the car back I'll
peel the egg for you the desire can
sometimes trump talent think about that
so that you may not have as much talent
as you think you have but if you have
the desire your talent will find you I
never anybody over in my life didn't
ever come to come back
all I have in this world is my balls and
my word and I don't break them for no to
understand that piece is it up there I
never liked him I never trusted him for
all I know he had me set up and had my
friend angel Fernandez killed but that's
history
I hear he's not do you want to go out
with me to say it you don't and you make
a move because I make little films
myself nobody sees them of course but I
make him on my own I made him in the old
days I when I had it I used to make him
with my own money
and that was kind of strange I was
accused of being crazy for doing that
and I'm I was but it was important for
me to learn film that way so I'm used to
I like it I like to mix it up a plane
goes to Miami all right
it's where I wanted met Mike that's
impossible
they'll turn you over directly to the
Internal Revenue customs and half the
FBI it's not impossible nothing's
impossible it would be like trying to
kill the president there's no way we can
get to it
Tom you know you surprised me if
anything in this life is certain if
history's taught us anything says you
can kill anyone I suggest reading of
course it's tough reading books these
days but you should I I really believe
in it is because you know uh the
Russians saved my life
when I was very young like your age and
and doing plays if you can if your
actives because the plays are what roles
that are asked challenge you it's a very
good for you because also you're doing
play is sometimes that asked of you a
lot of stuff I mean to ask you to do
more than some of these roles we get
cast for that don't ask that much of us
really I mean if naturalism we do it you
know you do this but the roles that ask
a lot of you is what where you develop
where you're you
you broaden your horizons your
imagination and what you learn from this
great literature I mean if you're a
cellist right you're gonna want to play
Bach no I mean why wouldn't you
you're a cellist Bach wrote for you
and and eventually you want to play it
you play anything on it but finally
that's what you want to play because
that's going to get you the kind of joy
the kind of excitement that is going to
change your life really change my life a
lot of the parts I played as a youngster
with made me broaden my my scope and my
understanding of things it's it's it's
really important to open yourself up to
that dirty cop right robbing the banks a
federal offense they got me on
kidnapping armed robbery they're gonna
bear with me man
I don't want to talk to somebody's
trying to calm you get somebody in
charges I am and try to let it talk to
some flunky Pig try to call me
you're not that we call you do it I will
you get back over there for [ __ ] back
window
he wants to kill me so bad he can taste
it I got always gonna kill ya my
instincts I always felt were better
earlier in my life than they are now it
seems as though sometimes I'm a little
bit blinded by the attention so I don't
make correct assessments I'm a little
bit influenced by the fact that I'm not
I'm not on the outside looking in I was
fortunate enough to have certain things
happen in my life I mean it's it's
really and persisting in a thing you
know what is that that he who persists
in his folly will one day be wise you
know I've gotten wise yet but I keep
persisting
[Music]
mr. Sam's doesn't want it he doesn't
need to be labeled still worthy of being
a bad man what the hell is that what is
your motto here boys inform on your
classmates save your hide anything short
of that we're going to burn you at the
stake well gentlemen when the [ __ ] hits
the fan some guys run and some guys stay
here's Charlie facing the fire and
there's George
hiding in Big Daddy's pocket and what
are you doing you're going to reward
George and destroy Charlie are you
finished mr. Slade
no I'm just getting warmed up I don't
know who went to this place William
Howard Taft William Jennings Bryan
William Tell whoever their spirit is
dead if they have a had one it's gone
you're building a rat ship here a vessel
for seagoing snitches and if you think
you're preparing these minnows for
manhood you better think again because I
say you are killing the very spirit this
institution proclaims it instills what I
share what kind of a show are you guys
putting on here today I mean the only
class in this act is sitting next to me
and I'm here to tell you this boy's soul
is intact it's non-negotiable you know
how I know someone here and I'm not
gonna say who offered to buy it only
Charlie here wasn't selling sir you're
out of order I don't I show you on order
you don't know what that all is mr.
Trask I'd show you but I'm too old I'm
too tired I'm talking blind if I were a
man I was five years ago I take a
flamethrower to this place I don't know
who the hell you think you're talking to
I've been around you know there was a
time I could see and I have seen boys
like these younger than these their arms
now their legs ripped off but there
isn't nothing like the sight of an
amputated spirit there is no prosthetic
for that you think you're merely sending
this splendid foot soldier back home to
Argonne with his tail between his legs
but I say you are executing his soul and
why because he's not a bad man
bad men you hurt this boy you're going
to be bad bums delaria and hairy Jimmy
Trent wherever you are there do you two
stand down mr. Slade I'm not finished as
I came in here I heard those words
cradle a leadership well when the bough
breaks the cradle will fall and it has
fallen here it has fallen make us a man
creators or leaders be careful what kind
of leaders you're producing here I don't
know if Charlie's silence here today is
right or wrong I'm not a judge or jury
but I can tell you this he won't sell
anybody out to buy his future and that
my friends is called integrity that's
called courage now that's the stuff
leaders should be made of
now I have come to the crossroads in my
life I always knew what the right path
was without exception I knew but I never
took it you know why it was too damn
hard
now here's Charlie he's come to the
crossroads he has chosen a path it's the
right path it's a path made a principle
that leads to character let him continue
on his journey you hold this boy's
future in your hands committee it's a
valuable future
believe me don't destroy it protect it
embrace it it's gonna make you proud one
day I promise you
I don't know what to say really three
minutes till the biggest battle of our
professional lives all comes down to
today either we heal as a team we're
going to crumble inch by inch play by
play till we're finished we're in Hell
right now gentlemen believe me and we
can stay here get the [ __ ] kicked out of
us or we can fight our way back into the
light we can climb out of hell one inch
at a time now I can't do it for you
I'm too old I look around I see these
young faces and I think I mean I made
every wrong choice a middle-aged man can
make
I uh I pissed away all my money believe
it or not I chased off anyone who's ever
loved me and lately I can't even stand
the face I see in a mirror you know when
you get old in life things get taken
from that's that's that's part of life
but you only learn that when you start
losing stuff you'll find out life's this
game of inches so is football because in
either game life or football the margin
for error is so small I mean one half a
step too late or too early and you don't
quite make it one half second too slow
too fast you don't quite catch it the
inches we need are everywhere around us
they're in every break of the game every
minute every second
on this team we fight for that inch on
this team we tear ourselves and everyone
else around us to pieces for that inch
long with our fingernails
because we know when we add up all those
inches that's gonna make the difference
between winning and losing
and died yes in any fight it's the guy
who's willing to die who's gonna win
that inch and I know if I'm gonna have
any life a it's because I'm still
willing to fight and die for that edge
that's what living is the six inches in
front of your face now I can't make you
do it you gotta look at the guy next
year look into his eyes now I think
you're gonna see a guy who will go to
that inch we held it up you're gonna see
a guy who will sacrifice himself for
this team because he knows when it comes
down to it you're gonna do the same for
him that's a team gentlemen yo yeah and
either we heal now as a team or we will
die as individuals
[Music]
as football guys
[Music]
that's all it is
now
what are you gonna do
[Music]
you
thank you guys so much for watching I
made this video because Dorian right
asked me to so there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Al's top
10 rules had the biggest impact on you
and why leave in the comments and I will
join in the discussion finally I want to
give a quick shout out to Jason Jay Rhys
Fonseca from Rhys online.com Jason
bought another copy of the book so I'm
giving a quick shout out thank you so
much Jason means a lot to me
those you guys watchin if you want your
chance at a shout out in the future
video make sure to buy a copy of book
and email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching
continue to believe or whatever your one
word is and I'll see you soon
[Music]
I had this ability to mimic I would I
would mimic the movies I would mimic any
of the current singers whether it was Al
Jolson or Sinatra or whoever it was and
I then got learned how to mimic
situations and people just for the fun
of it go get me some fo staleys where am
I gonna go a lot of us who are actors
have that sort of performer in us here
she got great ass and you got your head
all the way up it Robin Williams would
be the example of someone who really
lets you see it you know most of us have
it but we don't have his gifts to be
able to express it but the needs are
there if you're a shy person sometimes
you hide behind an image that you think
somebody has it's almost a pose that you
can let your guard down or commit to
anything and it's a way you can get into
the habit of doing that I did from is it
true don't ask me about my business no
it is in a way once you start getting
parts your learning process is gonna get
less and less anyway you're gonna be
given roles that you are so-called right
for quote unquote which is typecasting
which is a lot of baloney and you're
gonna get into that kind of thing and
you're not going to get a chance to grow
and stretch yourself
I used to use auditions as a way of
practicing what are you gonna do by
usually they'd have a script they wanted
me to read I'd say oh okay I prepared a
little something what are you gonna do
about it
[ __ ] and it was an opportunity to do
something that I had been working on and
you would work it out without ever
thinking about getting the role I'm a
journalist think use your head how do I
operate as a journalist by screwing the
people who could provide me with
information before they provided me with
I used to dream about John Locke of
course when it first happened and he was
always alive in a dream
see it's always there you know 30 years
I was doing a play called the basic
training of Pavle humble on Broadway and
it was a really great role and had I
done things with it may have done the
Tony Award and I was really a you ever
John was coming to see it and I don't
like to know when anyone's in the house
but I mean John was in the house right
and every single thing I did every scene
I was trying to impress John and I knew
I'm doing this was a me sound like doing
this I'm trying to impress John and it
was over and I was really unhappy
because I knew I hadn't done and John
came back and said it's very impressive
oh very impressive I thought yes dad
I said you know what I said he was so
graceful though he was so gracious about
Lala I said you know I knew you were
there and I was China I was doing
everything twice as much as I had to do
it yeah this was good that was good it
was good so you don't know you don't
realize that you know you've been airing
but I do I it so I was very young he was
like one of my idols so that when he was
coming to see me was you give all out
and that's the worst thing you can do is
try to impress your your friends who you
love what's the best direction you've
ever received on an on-set the best
direction where one of the best things
that comes to my mind now is this ad
Gaby Burt Harris on Dog Day Afternoon
well he came up to me I was in the first
of all he kept me sober every morning
she hit me with those tomato juices I
come in
some girl the other night was describing
knowing me and godfather to how I
committed with a crazy ass a scarves I
stuff and then I would have to turn into
Michael yeah right
slowly it was this good yeah I've become
this but anyway Bert Harris came up to
me
smart kid I'm a smart man and I was in
the middle of stuff and he just chemo me
whispered in my ear because we were in
dog they were out there with all the I
recommend the movie on a big screen if
you could ever see it to see what
Lynette does with a crowd and with the
street and to put you in it in such a
way it just is kinetic you can feel the
energy it was it was a turning point
yeah in films and in the way he did it
but anyway this guy Burt Burt Harris
camp comes up to me this is what I love
about movies too and he looked leans in
and he says say sciatica I said what he
said going to crown just yell out attic
okay
remember attic because Attica was a
prison that had had a lot of trouble and
terrible prisons were killed it was a
real scandal it was so in the world you
know it was right there and and uh I was
there all cases God you see this God so
I went out and there I am and there's
all these extras out there staying on
there all day long in there and they
start talking if looking in the cops'll
and I just say yeah what about Attica at
one point this had to become Isis Attica
and they lured to the crime I said hey
remember I go ah Chanukah and they went
yeah Monica
so he's Anika and all of a sudden this
thing Anika and
this became a [ __ ] a iconic moment
absolutely in the movies uh and that's
how it came about
hahahaha amazing know something yeah I
mean this is the way these things happen
in films if you're open to it and that's
the kind of brain that that Lynette had
but Bert how we would do things like
that and you know it just became this
magic magical possible you're out there
you got the room but when you're doing a
movie in six weeks you don't have time
for attic